es ist besser nicht zu regieren als
falsch zu regieren erinnert ihr euch das
ist die Haltung der FDP im November 2017
und ihre Absage an eine sogenannte
Jamaika-Koalition aus FDP GRÜNEN und CDU
vier Jahre später sortieren die liberal
mit SPD und Grünen und übernehmen am
Schluss tatsächlich
Regierungsverantwortung offenbar sind
sie diesmal die Chance richtig regieren
zu können in diesem Video hier schauen
wir uns an wie regiert die FDP bringen
sie die ampelregierung voran oder ist
sie der Bremsklotz der Ampel und was
sagen die Zahl des ZDF politbarometers
dazu
[Musik]
wen würden Sie wählen wenn am nächsten
Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre das hat das
ZDF Politbarometer auch Ende Juni wieder
gefragt die FDP erhält sechs Prozent
liegt also nur knapp über der 5% Hürde
schneller Rückblick auf die
Bundestagswahl im September 2021 die FDP
wird mit 11,5% führt stärkste Kraft die
Grünen liegen mit 14,8% auf Platz 3
schnell ist klar die beiden wollen es
miteinander versuchen stellt sich nur
die Frage mit wem als Seniorpartner
Jamaika oder Ampel es wird die Ampel
eine Koalition aus den zwei eher
linksverordneten Parteien SPD und Grünen
unter Liberalen FDP ob das gut gehen
kann nach der Regierungsbildung gehen
die Umfragewerte für die FDP nach und
nach in den Keller schon nach rund einem
halben Jahr mit der Ampel sprechen nur
noch 6 % der Befragten im ZDF
Politbarometer der FDP ihr Vertrauen aus
aus diesem Umfrage aktiv ist die FDP
seitdem nicht mehr richtig
herausgekommen war die große Zustimmung
bei der Bundestagswahl vielleicht nur
eine gute Phase für die Liberalen für
den Land das waren danach wird die FDP
immer wieder abgestraft im Saarland in
Niedersachsen und Berlin scheitert sie
an der 5% Hürde bei den Wahlen in
Schleswig-Holstein NRW und zuletzt
Bremen ist es denkbar knapp hat die
Partei die Erwartungen ihrer Wähler
vielleicht enttäuscht wer sind diese
Wähler überhaupt und was wurde ihnen
versprochen FDP da steht bekanntlich für
freie demokratische Partei im Leitbild
der Partei finden sich Werte wie
Freiheit Fairness Fortschritt und
Verantwortung für die Zukunft in diesem
Leitbild schreiben den Liberalen sie
wollen sich für Bildung einsetzen für
die Digitalisierung für
Chancengleichheit für Selbstbestimmtheit
Nachhaltigkeit und eine Politik die
rechnen kann vielleicht stellt die FDP
deshalb auch noch ein Wort mit F den
aktuellen Finanzminister Christian
Lindner ein Berufspolitiker wie er im
Buche steht tritt mit 16 Jahren in die
Partei ein mit 20 er ringt er sein
erstes Landtagsmandat in NRW und er muss
sich den Spitznamen Bambi gefallen
lassen heute ist der 44 Jahre alt und
steht seit inzwischen zehn Jahren an der
Spitze der FDP Lindner macht sich noch
als Schüler mit einer
Unternehmensberatung selbstständig und
ist so wahrscheinlich das beste Beispiel
für die typische Klientel der Liberalen
das sind traditionell eher
selbstständige Beamte leitende
Angestellte am meisten Wählerinnen und
Wähler hat die Partei in den Regionen
des Landes in denen das wirtschaftlich
gut läuft in Baden-Württemberg zum
Beispiel dem Land der Autobauer und
Autofahrer und dem einzigen Bundesland
in dem die FDP durchgehend im Landtag
vertreten ist dass man die FDP auch mal
die Porsche Partei nennt ist an der
Stelle wahrscheinlich reiner Zufall die
Gruppe der FDP Stammwähler ist relativ
klein weiß Andrea Boll von der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen wir sehen bei
der FDP allerdings schon dass sie
meistens in den Umfragen so im Bereich
zwischen fünf und zehn Prozent liegt bei
Bundestagswahlen
schneidet sie manchmal auch besser ab
also das war jetzt bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl so das war auch 2017 so
das war auch die zwei neuen so also das
sind oft zu Peaks wo die FDP dann eben
auch besser abschneidet und das hängt
sicherlich einfach mit den speziellen
Kontextfaktoren der Wahlen dann auch
zusammen also wie gut sind die anderen
Parteien aufgestellt wie attraktiv sind
die anderen Parteien welche
koalitionsüberlegungen treffe ich bei
der Stimmabgabe und da ist die FDP ja
auch meistens eine Partei die die dann
auch davon profitiert wenn man eine
bestimmte Koalition unterstützen möchte
bei seiner Wahl und von daher gibt es da
halt auch bei der FDP diese Schwankungen
bei der Bundestagswahl 2021 scheint die
Strahlkraft von Christian Lindner
besonders auf die jungen Wähler Eindruck
gemacht zu haben mehr als 20% ihrer
Zweitstimmen gehen an die FDP nach den
Grünen zweit meist gewählte Partei bei
den Jungen nach eineinhalb Jahren
Pandemie könnten es womöglich auch die
Versprechen nach Freiheit
Selbstbestimmung und Digitalisierung
gewesen sein die die sogenannte
Generationszeit angesprochen
und tatsächlich nach der Wahl stellt die
FDP nicht nur den Finanz- und den
Justizminister auch das Bildungs- und
das Ressort für digitales und Verkehr
gehen an die FDP die FDP könnte sich
also an die Umsetzung einiger ihrer
Wahlversprechen machen trotzdem die
Zustimmung zur FDP ist schnell
zusammengeschmolzen die Umfragewerte
sind im Keller sind es gerade die jungen
Wählerinnen und Wähler die sich schon
wieder abgewendet haben Volker bissing
ist der Minister für digitales und
Verkehr er ist zuständig für den Ausbau
der e-infrastruktur des ÖPNV der
Glasfasernetze um so für den Fortschritt
zu sorgen den die Parteien ihren vielen
FS verspricht alles für die Zukunft die
Wissen in dezember 2021 erklärt für uns
ist völlig klar wir brauchen
Klimaneutralität und zwar so schnell wie
möglich tatsächlich zeigt eine Umfrage
des ZDF politbarometers aus dem Juli
2023 dass der Klimawandel durchaus ein
Thema bei den Anhängern der FDP ist mehr
als die Hälfte macht sich deshalb große
oder sehr große Sorgen
gleichzeitig gehen rund einem Drittel
der FDP-Anhänger die Maßnahmen für den
Klimaschutz zu weit ja wenn man nach den
wichtig
sten Anhängerinnen der FDP das neben
diesem Thema Energiewende und Klima auch
das ökonomische Thema Inflation Kosten
Preise Löhne genauso wichtig erachtet
wird das heißt es ist nicht so wie in
der Gesamtheit des oberste Priorität im
Moment oder wichtigstes Problem
Energiewende Klima ist sondern für die
fdp-anhängerschaft ist es eben
beides wichtig ungefähr gleich wichtig
ne die Energiewende und auch die
ökonomische Situation und die
ökonomischen Probleme ja immer wieder
ist es die FDP die den Fortschritt Zug
und Gesetze rund um den Klimaschutz
ausbremst jüngstes Beispiel das Gebäude
Energiegesetz kurz heizungsgesetz
monatelang bremst die FDP lässt Robert
habe auflaufen bemängel
technologieoffenheit und erst kurz vor
der Sommerpause kommt es im letzten
Moment zu einer Einigung mit dem
Argument technologieoffenheit stellt
sich die FDP auch gegen das Aus von
verbrennermotoren und setzt auf EU-Ebene
letztlich e-fius als Kompromiss durch
mit der FDP wird es auch kein Tempolimit
geben egal wie oft beispielsweise das
Umweltbundesamt berechnet das langsamer
fahren besser für das Klima wäre
stattdessen will die FDP Autobahnen und
Brücken sanieren und ausbauen die Grünen
wollen das Geld hingegen lieber in
Klimaschutz investieren während die zwei
sich streiten steht die Verkehrswende
still der Fortschritt auch und
Deutschland läuft Gefahr seine
Klimaziele nicht zu erreichen aber dafür
hat Christian Lindner eine Erklärung es
ist nicht Volker Wissing der die
Klimaziele im Verkehr nicht erreicht es
sind die Bürgerinnen und Bürger hätten
die die Klimaziele nicht erreichen weil
die Menschen eben mobil sein wollen ja
kürzlich haben wir übrigens auch ein
Video über die Grünen gemacht denn das
ampelchaos geht auch an Robert Habeck
und Co nicht spurlos vorbei das Video
findet ihr oben auf dem i verlinkt die
dagegen Partei die Blockierer
fortschrittsbremser werden die Liberalen
immer wieder von Kritikern genannt seit
Beginn der Legislaturperiode könnte man
den Eindruck gewinnen die FDP
profitieren sich hauptsächlich dadurch
den beiden anderen ampelparteien in
Streit zu geraten so wollen SPD und
Grüne beispielsweise Verbesserungen im
Mietrecht ein Demokratie fördergesetz
oder die übergewinnsteuer einführen aber
die FDP ist immer erst einmal dagegen
blockiert Entscheidungen oder fordert
Nachbesserungen immerhin nach
monatelangem Ringen mit den
Koalitionspartnern gibt Finanzminister
Christian Lindner im Winter nach und
stimmte übergewinnsteuer für
Energiekonzerne zu je schlechter die
Umfragewerte der FDP werden und je mehr
Niederlagen sie etwa im Landtagswahlen
einfährt desto härter scheint der
Konfrontationskurs der FDP zu werden
manche sehen dabei schon parallel zur
sogenannten ihrer Westerwelle 2009 bis
2013 ist die FDP Juniorpartner in einer
Regierung mit der Union auch damals
gelingt es denn Liberalen nicht ihre
Anliegen gegenüber dem Koalitionspartner
durchzusetzen die FDP wirkt unzufrieden
und zerrissen das Ergebnis bei der
nächsten Wahl fliegt sie aus dem
Bundestag raus ein Trauma gegen das
viele in der Partei mutmaßlich gerade
ankämpfen
anders lautstark äußert sich
beispielsweise fdp-urgestein Wolfgang
Kubicki etwa gegenüber dem SPIEGEL nach
der Wahlschlappe bei der Berliner
Landtagswahl schickte einen Gruß zu
Robert Habeck wenn es keine Straßenbau
mehr geben soll dann gibt es auch keine
neuen Stromleitungen mehr da kann sich
der Robert gehackt legen und wie finden
die FDP-Anhänger diese Haltung die
anderen Anhänger der Regierungsparteien
also die Anhängerschaft der SPD und der
Grünen die sagen auch jetzt mehrheitlich
Regierung und Kanzler machen ihren Job
gut aber bei den fdp-anhängen deren
Partei ja auch Mitglied der
Bundesregierung ist
da ist es anders da sagen die meisten
die machen einen schlechten Job die FDP
ist ja in der Regierung schon diejenige
die auch oft Kontakt gibt ja die anders
als die anderen Parteien sich
positioniert in bestimmten Themen und
das führt dann wahrscheinlich auch dazu
dass die fdp-anhängerschaft dann eben
hier auch eher in Opposition geht im Mai
2023 sieht ein Drittel der Befragten des
ZDF politbarometers die Schuld bei der
FDP das Regierungsvorhaben nur schleppen
Vorankommen lediglich 3% schieben das
vor allem auf die SPD 18 auf die Grünen
der Rest meint alle sind gleich Schuld
immerhin einer hält das Licht am Ende
des Tunnels hoch Christian Lindner im
Politbarometer ist der seit langem der
einzige FDP-Politiker unter den Top Ten
also den zehn wichtigsten Politikerinnen
und Politikern des Landes seit rund
einem Jahr sind seine Beliebtheitswerte
leicht im negativen Bereich aber Lindner
hat sich im Mittelfeld der Top Ten einen
festen Platz gesichert wenn ihr euch
fragt wie diese Liste überhaupt zustande
kommt auch das haben Thema erklärt das
Video findet ihr oben auf dem i im April
23 geben 40 Prozent der Befragten des
ZDF politbarometers an Christian Lindner
könne die Partei erfolgreich in die
Zukunft führen optimistischer sind die
Anhänger der FDP hier trauen Lindner
ganze 82 Prozent einen Erfolg zu ihr
sitzt also nach wie vor fest am Steuer
führt seine Partei durch
koalitionskrisen und in zwei schwierige
Wahlkämpfe im Oktober stehen die
Landtagswahlen in den beiden
Flächenländern Bayern und Hessen an
aktuell sind die Liberalen in beiden
Landtagen noch vertreten aber vor allem
die wichtigen Sitze im Münchner Landtag
könnten Experten zufolge im Herbst
verloren gehen besser gar nicht regieren
als falsch regieren das war 2017 noch
das mutige Statement der FDP und die
eigene Rechtfertigung damals lieber die
Opposition zu gehen aber während die FDP
in der Ampel die Regierungsvorhaben
weiter bremst freut sich die aktuelle
Opposition schließlich übernimmt die FDP
quasi ihren Job und wenn drei sich
streiten in dem Fall grün und gelb dann
freut sich eine dritte in dem Fall blau
die AFD schwebt auf einem noch nie da
gewesenen Umfrage Hoch wenn ihr wissen
wollt wer die AFD wählt dann klickt oben
auf das i da kriegt ihr ein Video dazu
und falls euch andere Videos unsere
Reihe politbarometer2go interessieren
dann kann ich euch die gesamte Playlist
ans Herz legen die findet ihr hier neben
mir wie seht ihr das glaubt ihr die
Regierung wäre effektiver wenn die FDP
nicht erst einmal dagegen wäre schreibt
gerne in die Kommentare und schreibt
auch gerne ob euer Eindruck vielleicht
ein ganz anderer ist danke schonmal
dafür und bis zum nächsten Mal